alors pour moi le moment le plus
marquant c'est quand vous avez reçu sur
le plateau pierre et Maryse le coupe de
retraités Marseille dans la maison était
occupé illégalement par Nadia ça nous a
occupé pendant plusieurs émissions et
grâce à vous grâce à la médiatisation
que vous avez occasionné cette affaire
c'est réglé et pour moi c'est symbolique
de tout ce que vous avez fait depuis
septembre merci parler de tas de
problèmes et les régler
vous avez fait avancer les choses voilà
si c'est pour moi le moment merci Gilles
c'était le 29 septembre dernier vous
rappelez de ça ou pas
ah oui bah oui alors ça me dérange pas
ce sont des images qui m'apportaient
votre agence d'accord
simplement aujourd'hui en fait je suis
venue m'expliquer m'excuser moi je ne
savais pas tout ce que vous subissiez
d'accord
vous êtes dans vos droits d'accord moi
je suis locataire moi j'ai fait
confiance à une agence tout simplement
Nadia est-ce que aujourd'hui vous êtes
prêtes à quitter le logement oui ça fait
longtemps que j'essaye de le quitter
vous savez moi je suis prêt à vous aider
aussi pour que vous partiez le plus vite
possible peut-être à essayer de vous
aider pendant un mois le temps que vous
trouviez quelque chose comme ça Pierre
et Marie il retrouve leur logement dès
demain qu'il puisse passer le week-end
dans leur maison et que vous on puisse
éventuellement voilà vous trouvez
quelque chose pendant un mois qu'on
puisse voilà vous aider pendant un mois
le temps que vous trouviez autre chose
Kelly c'est quoi ton moment toi tu
retiens alors moi c'est mon chroniqueur
préféré d'amour numéro 1 de tous les
jours c'est Gilles ce qui m'a trop trop
fait rire et me fait rire à chaque fois
et pour moi c'est le meilleur à tous les
niveaux c'est quand il a fait son entrée
au foot quand il est tard moi je suis
souvent pas aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il
peut rester rooter des gens chez lui
comme ça il peut faire plein de choses
mais c'est quelqu'un de de sympa c'est
le meilleur voilà alors c'est bon des
chroniqueurs voilà le meilleur il a été
désigné par les téléspectateurs c'est
Guillaume j'entends et c'est celui qui
me donne le plus d'argent
le rapport forcément les spectateur une
fois de plus vous pouvez résoudre de
toute façon
offensif de l'équipe il est en train de
cadrer sa première frappe à nouveau
attention il frappe il va dévisser mais
oui ça y est c'est le but c'est le but
de but
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous souhaite d'être aussi belle de
façon 58
[Rires]
je vois pas en fait à chaque fois qu'on
parle de toi tu lui
dise
important la première qualité chez un
homme c'est la gentillesse
la gentillesse la gentillesse toutes les
femmes sont lentilles
sont formidables
[Applaudissements]
on fait partie Jean-Marie Bigard ça
c'est un homme franchement c'est vrai
après il y en a deux autres
je dirais pas la même chose voilà les
trois voilà les trois voilà c'est des
mecs gentils exactement Gilles
Jean-Marie après il y a deux autres
personnes qui ont d'autres qualités
voilà mais ce ne sont pas leurs qualités
alors qualité première voilà moi voilà
je le dis
Raymond justement tiens c'est dur d'être
gentil oh moi alors moi les les moments
préférés c'est quand vous offrez des
trucs aux gens et quand vous parlez au
public moi ça tout le temps était ça dès
que vous offrez des trucs au public ou
aux gens et bah c'est quand l'autre fois
vous avez fait descendre des gens du
public on s'est tous assis là sur le net
et tu disais tiens à toi je t'emmène au
Maroc toi je t'emmène en Grèce toi tu
vas en Turquie je te je kiffe ça
est-ce que vous voulez pas faire une
petite danse avec Mathieu
est-ce que tu as envie de danser avec
Mathieu non mais non mais non non non
[Applaudissements]
attention Serge Serge je t'aime beaucoup
mais je te montre en enlever ton slip
non monsieur
on va faire une petite danse hein on va
on va se rapprocher et si ils ont 10
minutes on se place
parce qu'on est en train de me dire le
cadre et les mecs je vous annoncer un
truc tout à l'heure fort
pour l'instant je suis sous le saut de
la confidentialité
et pas là il est parti avec sa femme au
voyage
tiens Bernard oui alors moi j'étais très
très très ému en plus il était à côté de
moi mais au-delà de ça c'est Julien le
boulanger c'est assez récent mais je
dois dire que là j'étais bouleversé
parce qu'il représente à la fois un peu
cette France qui souffre et dont il faut
s'occuper vraiment parce que ces
situations là sont inadmissibles vous
leur donnez tout le temps la parole et
j'étais vraiment bouleversé j'étais très
bouleversé
j'ai envie de trouver un truc ah ouais
non vraiment c'est pas possible des
situations
c'est pas possible
je suis en dépression je pense je veux
plus voir personne c'est voilà quoi
c'est tout le travail d'une vie quand
même c'est 5 ans moi j'ai fait 5 ans de
ma vie là-dedans c'est on prône la
baguette au patrimoine de l'Unesco
qu'est-ce qu'on va [ __ ] cette baguette
à l'Unesco ça fait déjà bien longtemps
qu'elle devrait y être mais [ __ ] mais
les boulangeries sont en train de crever
à petit feu et on va mettre la baguette
au patrimoine de l'Unesco c'est moi je
prends ça comme de la provoc je suis
désolé on nous provoque quoi c'est tout
le monde croit qu'on a des aides parce
que dans les médias il sort tous les
gros titres l'État et les TPE les PME
mais parmi rien du tout rien du tout je
veux dire où nous sommes rien non moi
j'ai le droit à 0 aide alors forcément
j'ai attaqué Bruno Le Maire et Olivia
Grégoire sur certains médias donc j'ai
eu le bureau de Madame Grégoire qui m'a
appelé cette semaine pour savoir
qu'est-ce qui se passait donc j'ai
l'impression d'entendre Emmanuel Macron
je vous entends je vous écoute on est là
pour vous mais arrêtez votre pipeau moi
je lui ai dit ça marche pas votre
propagande à deux balles mais j'ai le
droit à 0 aide je tiens à le dire parce
que je rentre pas dans les critères il y
a il y a un nombre incalculable de
critères qu'on nous a sorti
forcément les boulangers nous on n'est
pas dedans je suis désolé là c'est
impossible de repartir ah non mais moi
je veux même plus Cyril hein je suis
dégoûté du système moi je veux même plus
mettre un pied dans une boulangerie moi
c'est fini quoi c'est je vais me
reconvertir avant un boulot gagner ma
vie convenablement et plus d'emmerde
plus rien je fais des ulcères je fais
des migraines des blocages de dos je
vais dire j'ai 32 ans j'ai jamais fait
de mal
ah ouais ouais on pense à lui on va
essayer on verra bien
les chéris Valérie c'est quoi ton alors
c'est beaucoup plus souriant et c'est un
souvenir qui moi me fait très plaisir et
on n'est jamais vu ça vite par soi-même
c'est quand régulièrement je vous mets
des bonnes
non
j'adore le téléphone
[Rires]
perdra son iPhone et je l'offrirai à
quelqu'un du public
[Applaudissements]
on va bien
[Rires]
c'est-à-dire si les dieux
le smartphone me regarde que Benaim
termine en enfer chez Funhouse
[Rires]
excusez-moi vous avez quand même
conscience que vous applaudissez un
escroc en
[Applaudissements]